well tomorrow is saint patrick's day and
we're heading to new york
to get a sneak peek at all the safe fun
they're planned yeah of course we're
talking about the new york new york
hotel
on the strip rocky theist joins us there
live hey rocky
hey you guys yes so we are already
having a lot of fun here
for st patrick's day which is tomorrow
of course but we're getting the party
started early
because the new york new york has so
much planned so
let's start with the drinks because you
can't do st patty's day without
drinks and i'm going to take a wild
guess as to what
goes into a saint patrick's day drink
looking back here
sour apple sauce not really
no no i mean it's the color though it's
a good color yes for safe patties
you don't want to get pinched okay
you're right but no not really we don't
put apple stuff in our in our especially
okay so then let's talk about what you
do offer okay
well one of our famous shots here is our
green teaser shot
um it's a green tea shot but we call it
the green
teaser quote-unquote i love it um so it
has jameson
peach schnapps sweet and sour and the
most important ingredient
is love oh that's so sweet yes
oh that is that is delicious i like that
i could finish that but i won't
absolutely i won't finish it
she can but she won't all right so now
let's talk about
the famous one the number one that you
guys actually have on the menu all the
time
yeah what's that called um well we have
an irish mule um our mule kick is one of
our most popular drinks
but since in saint patty's we definitely
want to highlight jameson
and we're using that for our irish mule
so our jameson
oh whoa wait a minute here
is what we use um now this is in our
well this is a premium spirit in our
well so if you go to tom's urban
our well has premium spirits in there so
love that you definitely want to make
sure you check out this cocktail all
right jameson's famous saint patrick's
day
absolutely so while you make that jay
why don't you make that and you get all
fancy over here i'm gonna talk to jason
over here
who runs things okay so jason let's talk
about how people can enjoy st
patty's day here at new york new york in
general yeah so
as you can see new york new york is the
ultimate destination for
for a fun and a safe st patrick's day
but tomorrow
we are going to have multiple food and
beverage specials here at toms urban
as well as our nine fine irishman irish
pub
as well as on a bridge so out on our
brooklyn bridge
out front so you can enjoy beer gardens
you can also enjoy our pepsi wild cherry
experience on the center bridge
uh interactive games uh it's just a lot
of fun
okay well i'm looking forward to that
coming up later in the show we're
actually going to go check out
everything you just mentioned on the
brooklyn bridge
it doesn't get much better than that all
right you ready you're gonna you're
gonna have to
help me garnish this oh oh wait a minute
i gotta wrap it i gotta rest
yeah here we go there it is boom we're
ready to drink that was awesome
i'll send it back to you guys cheers
cheers she gets all the good assignments
wow i'm jealous well